JOANNE STUBBE: My lab works
on the only cool enzyme
in the world--
ribonucleotide reductase.
It's the only way
in all organisms
that you make the
building blocks de novo
that are required for DNA
biosynthesis and repair.
So if you inhibit this enzyme,
you have no building blocks.
You can't survive.
So from a practical
point of view,
it's the target of drugs
they use therapeutically
in the treatment of cancer.
And I think in probably
not so distant future
in the antibacterials
because I think
there are sufficient differences
between humans and bacteria
reductases that you could
make specific inhibitors.
Why am I interested in it?
Because the chemistry
is sort of unbelievable.
So I mean it was the first
example where you learn,
or you hear about--
you heard from John--
radicals.
They're reactive oxygen
species and nitrogen species
that you can't control.
They want to pick
up an extra electron
and form a stable octet.
And if you leave them
to their own demise,
they react with
anything and destroy it.
Well nature has figured
out how to harness
the reactivity of radicals
to do really tough chemistry
with exquisite specificity.
And ribonucleotide reductases
have been the paradigm
for thinking about that.
And from bioinformatics
now there
are 50,000 reactions
in metabolic systems
that are going to be radical
mediated transformations,
yet we never talk about radicals
in introductory courses.
So I think that's
all going to change.
So why is it unusual?
Well, for the human
ribonucleotide reductase,
the key to making this
work catalytically
is the amino acid
side chain tyrosine
needs to be oxidized
to a tyrosyl radical.
So automatically
nobody believes that.
A tyrosyl radical
in solution has
a half-life of a microsecond.
In the active site
of these enzymes,
the half-life of the enzyme
can be on the order four days.
And this radical, which
is again one electron
oxidized amino acid--
if you reduce it
with an electron and a proton,
the enzyme is completely dead.
So this was the
first example of-- it
would be another example of a
post-translational modification
that we talked about earlier--
modifying your amino acids.
And so nature has
figured out a way.
How do you do this oxidation?
She has a little metal cluster
right adjacent to where
this tyrosine is.
And the function of this
little metal cluster
is to put this into the
oxidized state, which
is essential for the
way the enzyme works.
So the other thing that's
amazing about the enzyme
is the chemistry.
There are two subunits.
The chemistry all
happens in this subunit,
but the tyrosyl
radical is there.
And this oxidation-- normally
when you do an oxidation
the two atoms are sitting within
a few angstroms of each other--
the oxidation happens
over 35 angstroms.
So that's unprecedented.
It involves hopping
radicals which
no one has ever seen before.
And so that was
another thing that
was completely fascinating
from a chemical perspective
about how the system works.
The other reason that
people in biology
are interested in this, besides
the fact that makes a building
block for DNA, is that if
you believe in an RNA world
where we have a ribosome where
a catalysis of peptide bond
formation is all with the
RNA, not with the protein.
How do you get from an
RNA world to a DNA world?
The only enzyme that
does that transformation
making these building blocks
are ribonucleotide reductases.
And there are many classes of
ribonucleotide reductases--
one uses this tyrosyl radical--
but they all have
the same active site
and do the same
chemistry, but they
have different metal
cofactors depending
on where they evolved.
And the function of the
metal cofactors in all cases,
even though one's cobalt,
one's iron sulfur cluster,
one's manganese, one's iron--
the function in all cases
is to generate a radical
in the active site
and then the chemistry
is the same in all these things.